we have watched
unguided
[Music]
we have helped them progress
[Music]
unseen them accomplish wonders
salma i'm gonna start with you because i
feel
just listening to the way you talked
about it it's something that you
definitely sort of had to deal with when
you started telling people that you were
doing this and something that you wanted
to do for a long time so i'm just
curious in your life who had the best
reaction to your casting or was it you
because i have a feeling it might have
been you okay if it's not in my in if
it's in my family it's my husband but
actually i have a friend
her name is samantha
and she is mexican and she is obsessed
with comics and superheroes and marvel
she's a grown woman mind you but she
knows everything she is obsessed
and i couldn't tell her for so long
oh because we had to keep quiet for you
keep quiet yeah and i wanted to ask her
because she was going to give me the
bible of who i was
and that that went just like it was like
a telenovela she just
shook and cry and cry and cry she said
you're not joking no no
for real
and she was just uh by the way she said
director and she was just i like out of
her mind he was really i can't wait for
her to see it strange to watch her i
know
um and then i again i think i know but
why don't you tell me who had the best
reaction to you
really
i figured it would have been one of your
kids i knew who was who had the best
reaction
me i was asked
in the movie
i mean i think i think my kids you know
what's so funny is when you're mom and
you're such a mom
and they know me and they know me like
and i think there's that like that's so
great mom but mo like mom
you know so it became this like it was
going to be really fun i think they were
excited to
meet the other people excited to you
know for my family
the diversity within the cast
is so wonderful on for so many reasons
and it's just right and it's just due
time and it's
it just felt as it should very natural
and as it is
but it felt very nice from from my
family where i they're you know we just
it feels like a movie for them they're
characters that they're in you know it's
not
and there's been lots of different
representation in different separate
films but not the same family
yeah all together in one family that
felt more
so for my family i was very happy to be
a part of this and that's that's part of
what i love about the diversity of it
that it is diverse but it's one family
yes and and
every in every family everybody is
different you can even if they look
alike yeah they have the same color even
everybody is different and it's
celebrating different
yeah and and i think that is the best
part and it's not just with who they are
their personalities um you know their
physical appearance but i mean more
importantly like their powers and what
they bring to this team and i i do have
to say like the natural question is
always going to be like is it your power
the one that you want or are you envious
of maybe one of the other eternals
powers so some i'll start with you is
there one of the other's power that you
would want or maybe you want to keep
your eye on i felt like i i was stolen
because my character
in the comics flies
whoa
i didn't let you fly
no they didn't don't think i did not
die
i kind of glide a little but they don't
let me fly so we're saying though the
difficulty is in the comics we all have
almost every power and it's just almost
impossible to make a film if we're all
great at everything that's true
extremely so we kind of had to they had
to select
so we could hold up against each other
so we could but i like you when you're
gliding i like the idea of you gliding
though yeah i do like to at least float
it a little bit a little bit we have to
work together a little angelina the
problem is that
she normally glides in real life like
when she
so the problem here is like you know
ground yourself you can't with this
ethereal creature she well you are
but you know because she like you if you
watch her walk through the room she's
like already gliding no i mean yes and i
it's very difficult as a girl who bought
out the entire delias catalog to try and
emulate what she did in hackers not to
get starstruck right now i literally
were my first fashion
like inspiration as a kid so
yeah it's been it's been a minute for me
to try and keep professionalism and
you're right she does glide um but i
will i'll ask you the same question um
which power would you want to possess of
the eternals well it's interesting i
think we were all strangely cast as
ourselves
right and not nothing but something
about us
we were cast because there's something
about us that fits the person you know
it it is natural to you to be that the
healer and the mother and the you know
it's natural to me to be a little
aggressive and a bit emotional
and
a little you know and obsessed with no
and all about justice justice and
loyalty
so so in a way i i think i was
i was very and you know i think the fun
too when i first came in they said
i thought i had my staff
with the crescent
and then i said what are my weapons i
need to practice
and then he kept sending me weapons and
i kept thinking is marvel indecisive or
why is nobody telling me what's going on
and then they said no it's every weapon
like they're all and i was at first a
bit
taken aback and then i thought how cool
is that i can
every weapon does that mean i get thor's
hammer
i mean
that's it that's the t right there
because i'm a dollar powder of the
universe and now it's like who you want
to go up against and let me just say a
fight between you and thor there is not
a amount of money i would not pay to see
that
i'm like yeah yeah
i think we should i think i can make it
what do you mean you're right yeah what
we're talking about
he would get starstruck
with the valkyrie
yeah no i i would absolutely think you
could take thor um one la one little
thing real quick before we get out of
here too because some of your character
as both the leader of the group but also
the healer
it's it's such a interesting dichotomy
for the group to have the person who's
leading them is also the person that's
healing them and i was just curious like
for you
did that make i think some aspects of
the filming more difficult less
difficult because i feel like it's just
it's like you feel the cost of all these
characters
i'll tell you what for me
that's what leaders
were supposed to be yes
people should get in a position of power
to heal
to evolve
and uh not to get
obsessed with the power itself they
forget that they're working
for the people
and supposed to heal the differences
between the people
they're supposed to heal their pain
you know their ability to feel
their in
their inability to to feel power
people feel powerless right now yeah and
so
it's not much of a conflict because
that's what i believe a healer i mean
a leader should be
but
i do she does have a lot of conflicts
because she has a sense of duty
but then she also has her own sense of
justice
and
she feels
and she cares she kind of like
approaches leadership as a as a mother
which again that's how every leader
should approach leaders
i've directed some things too it was so
great seeing your characters it was so
great watching them just like kick butt
on during the premiere like that opening
scene where you guys really sort of show
your abilities i i absolutely loved it
but it made me have the question
which one of the eternals
is like the one whose power you'd want
to have personally so lauren i'll start
with you whose power would you want to
have or maybe you just want to keep your
own power from your character
i can keep my own power okay i think i
do like my power the most
um just because
it's really nice like in real life i do
run and i would love to run like
it's so effortless
and she can go around the world could
you imagine running around
i mean no but i definitely like the idea
of not having to fly ever again like
not have to get on a plane so i'm about
that yeah if i could just be like we're
going to milan and just be there yeah
i'm about that uh camille what about you
well now i'm trying to find a power that
would also allow me to skip planes
because now i'm going to go other
countries but i don't want to be on the
plane
icarus he can fly
you know i would fly
fly wherever i want to go
yeah i think i'm like weird because i
would want
berries uh i want druid's power and not
to like control people like like a
leader i would just want to like when
people are being evil i would want them
to like be nice so like you don't still
use it for good i would use it for good
i would not use it for evil
first week you're good the first week by
the second week you're just like this is
my parking space
oh my god you know what i do think that
power could corrupt someone as as uh
maybe we see in the film i have to ask
both of you this because i think one of
the coolest things in the world would be
to be in the movie like this to be able
to play a superhero and to know
especially with with both of you that
this may be the first time that someone
sees themselves as a superhero on screen
but i'm going to start with you lauren
who had the best reaction to your
casting because i feel like the people
around you you you're getting ready to
go to work you know there's going to be
a lot of work in long days but the
people around you i'm sure were very
excited when they found out and i wonder
who had the best reaction knowing you're
going to be in eternals
that's
funny so my boys really
my
son
i mean he kind of seemed unfazed
i was like i'm going to be a superhero
he's kind of like cool and then my my
youngest son who's seven um he i grabbed
my laptop we looked it up we're doing
some research who's the fastest and then
he's like
no makari's not that fast mom i'm not
impressed i'm pretty sure that flash is
going to be faster than you i was like
excuse me but so i did love their
reactions and they really kept me
grounded throughout the whole thing but
then
um the lego figure came out
and from then on it was over my boys
after that were impressed and then you
had it you had to win
it takes a lot to impress kids so that's
like a double win i love that um i think
i know your answer camille but who had
the best reaction to your casting
i mean it was emily my wife you know
because
she was literally the first one to know
that she was the first person i called
um and you know when they first called
me and they said hey so marvel wants to
have a meeting it's chloe zhao and nate
moore and i knew chloe was directing
eternals and i knew nate was producing
it and emily was like they don't want
you to be a superhero and i was like
emily please just calm down i don't
think that's true and i couldn't meet
with them for a couple weeks you know
but but i had the meeting they said we
want you to play this character and soon
right afterwards i called emily and she
was just so excited
and you know completely believed that i
could do it and honestly for months the
only people that knew were emily and
like you know the agents who have to do
the deal so so really really nobody knew
and i told my parents and i think they
kind of didn't believe it they were like
so which superhero i was like
ah kingo you haven't heard of him yet
but but there will be lego figures
yeah i love that um also your character
kumail i think when we were reading the
reviews on rotten tomatoes we did like a
first like social reactions piece scene
stealing came up a lot um in that one
and i'm just wondering like
were you able to lean on like your
stand-up comedy aspect of this how much
was in the script because it feels like
yeah like it it just was this character
was just designed to
rob every scene that he was in
oh thank you that's very very kind of
you you know i mean honestly talking
about the character
it's all chloe you know she sort of came
up with this character and she wanted us
all to put a little bit of ourselves
into each character you know and the
reason
that i think kingo works is because of
all the other characters around him you
know like all the characters in this
movie are so defined and our
relationships to each other are so
defined that's what allows you know
um that's what allows my character to be
sort of a little little different
everybody feels a little different you
know and i was very grateful that i got
to have like a couple short scenes with
makari in the movie because you know
when there are 10 people you don't get
to have all those little things so i was
very excited that the first time you see
me
it's me and makari beating someone and
then and then talking to each other and
that later in the movie we get to sort
of reconnect and have like it's a very
short conversation but it i really liked
it
i loved it and you're bringing me to my
next point for you lauren um which is
that i loved learning yesterday how
involved you were in coming up with a
lot of the the signing language for the
characters and and the creation of those
just talk us through that because the
only one i can remember and possibly
because it was easy is kingu
like that was like so great so
yeah
oh yeah that's a great one yes so yeah
talk us through it
i do want to back up a little bit
because i want to add something to
kamal's comment kamel's comment um
stealing scenes being a scene robber you
know
yes chloe really wanted just to bring a
lot of ourselves and put those into the
character and i would say kingo
i mean yes he's natural scene stealer
and i would say the same
for kumel
sorry i keep butchering the name and
it's really natural he is a stealer he
is funny he's great at ad-libbing and i
think that chloe
i mean she was really lucky to get
someone like him because whenever you're
directing a scene
she would be like can you do your improv
thing and then he's like okay and then
they would go and eat it
it was beautiful
and
um okay now back to your weight what was
your question
oh yeah right yeah about the signing
yeah yes you're asking about the signing
and so i just want to let you know it
wasn't really me um it was mostly the
work of my husband who he was the asl
consultant for this film
and
um he worked with camel and we had
worked in collaboration together my
husband and i um coming up with
different name signs for each of the
characters and i do have to let you know
that there are some easter eggs um
for example kingo
i mean obviously
it's based on his power he shoots lasers
he has laser guns and then he also is a
bollywood dancer and so it's kind of
like a nice mix but
it also happened to be the name sign of
my youngest son
wyatt oh
and so yeah it's just between us it's a
nice little easter egg and then makari
so that's my character's name sign from
the face and it does represent speed
that she zooms that's what that sign
means
um and it's really close to the ear and
we picked that because i don't know if
you can see in the movie but makari
tends to wear a lot of earrings she has
these beautiful earrings on her ears and
so we based that from there
and in real life that happened to be the
name sign for my husband his name sign
is douglas
that's superman with the cape and you're
shooting laser beams out of your eyes
i don't wear a cape
first of all congratulations on the film
it's incredible and both of you are so
incredible in it and what i think is so
great about it is you guys play this
love story that plays out over literally
centuries um like in a determined amount
of time i'm just curious if you have a
favorite lover from out history like
that you like either literary fictional
even if it's someone from the mcu like
i've played romeo twice so i've always
got a real kind of
um a real tie to him and how he sees the
world i mean he's stupid but
he's he could pull it and i like that
dig it gosh do you mean fictional um
whatever i mean real life fictional like
again wherever you choose to go ma'am
oh my goodness if you go back to http
could it be like cleopatra someone like
well which one mark anthony or caesar
well no we'll clear it cleopatra
yeah oh just click
just
i actually dig that i like that answer i
really dig that answer um it's so great
to see you guys in the eternals because
they're these they're this super team
that all bring a different sort of power
and their powers um really sort of
combine to make them really great but
they individually have their own
strength and i'm just curious
maybe it's a hard question to answer but
gemma who do you think is the most
powerful eternals and it's okay if you
want to say yourself by the way well
like you said they all have their
different strengths
and i suppose it depends on the context
as well
i mean if we're talking kind of sheer
you know fighting brute strength kind of
power it's obviously it's not cersei uh
but she has
i mean if i i mean i will have to say
spoilers
um
her powers develop over the course of
the film as well so she kind of doesn't
even know how powerful she is
so
yeah
dig that um i'll follow up with this
then whose power would you want to have
if you could have one and then richard
i'll come to you with the same question
i think it'd be pretty cool to have ajax
power to be able to heal
oh that's such a great one too
yeah i mean
she'd have a job for life she'd just be
going around
i'm trying to hit everyone
i'm so not that altruistic i'm like let
me be what what jude has i want to just
control people like i'm sorry maybe
that's probably said something really
bad about me but i would do like he did
to like end war to end hypocrisy and to
make the world a better place so
uh richard what about you whose power
would you want to have i just want to
fly i think you know
so your character gets to fly so i get i
get it i get it everybody likes to fly
but i don't want to fly i'm not a fan of
flying in the modern sense so why would
i want to do it without a big
like i'm already terrified of flying so
i get it um the next thing i was going
to ask you richard is
um and i guess you could probably say
one way or the other because i know you
guys did this but which is harder to
sort of like get beat up for doing the
eternals or doing game of thrones
because both of them seem like you just
have to do so much both physical and
like a lot of like different locations
so which one do you feel is a little bit
more difficult i think eternals was
definitely harder just with the
the game of thrones you can you know
you're in all the heavy costumes and
swinging swords and that kind of stuff
um but you know kind of 12 hours hanging
three flights up and diving down and
flipping over and going round and round
and round that kind of stuff is that's a
lot of work um you know the work that i
enjoy about you really yeah by the end
of the day you pray battered and bruised
oh i can only well the result was
breathtaking so i appreciate all of the
bruises that you went through your pain
brought us immense pleasure how about
that
uh and gemma this is not your first time
in the mcu
but like just real top is it just nice
not to have to be blue
like this time around
i was finding you know when i did
captain marvel blue paint in like
crevices like you know months later
um no it was much better this time
around in terms of just a few hours in
the makeup chair you know um
yeah it's fun to just
yeah lee and
you know cersei's a really different
character and
i mean minerva a lot more physical i
would say i did a lot of kind of um kind
of physical fight training because
obviously
she was a warrior but cersei was more
about trying to tap into
um
her emotions her um you know finding
those kind of truthful beats amongst the
kind of spectacle of the film which was
that was a different challenge
and honestly i think that's the part
that folks are going to be really
surprised when they see it is throughout
all of this the the five different folks
whether it be the more thinkers and the
warriors like that gives the film a
duality too both on like how much it's
really like speaks to emotion and then
also just
really has a lot of great action um
another thing i think is interesting
again since you guys sort of go
throughout the time period in history um
but more in the mcu if you could plop
your character into any moment within
that timeline where would you want them
to be would you want them to be like
fighting thanos and end game or would
you want them to go like hang out with
the guardians of the galaxy um and jim
i'll start with you why she said they've
been around for so long they could kind
of have have hung out with with everyone
really um
i
i think it would have been fun to hang
out with though
yeah
you're in valkyrie and that bunch yeah
i'm with you and not like the fun but
also like not not hard on the eyes like
real
the the guardianship i think yeah
they're really pretty um what about you
richard uh where would you want to maybe
pop into the mcu go hang out with
somebody else i'd be straight in with
the guardians i think i think those guys
look like they're having a good time
they are partying and running around so
i think i want to jump in with them and
see what trouble we can cause of all the
powers i would say that they all like
have usefulness in like i would say
everyday situation so like yeah you want
to fly maybe i want to control things
but like when would you want to have
like maybe lauren's super speed or
sprite's ability to like change who she
is like what is the situation where it'd
be really nice to have
the eternals power so you can maybe
escape it a bit and gemma will start
with you
gosh um
i would want to do lauren when i had to
study for tests
like every time i had to study
maybe anywhere where there's like a long
line for something and you know if
you're stuck in security through the
airport you could just do a sprite
illusion just go through not have to dig
there
i dig that what about you richard
it would definitely be straight
spray illusions like when i'm working
and they're like we want you to be
filming this at the moment but also we
need you over here doing
we've got you on the second unit doing
this pickup i'm like if i could just
make multiples of me and they could go
and do everything and maybe i could just
stay at home that would be
this is what the end of the world looks
like
at least we have front row seats
i just have to say it's so exciting that
folks are going to get to see this movie
very soon and we were blessed to see it
early but the thing i really loved is
how each of you got to display your
powers pretty early on in the movie and
kit you also show up very early without
powers but still very early with your
own individual i would say powers but i
definitely want to start with you don if
you had to choose an eternal's power
whose would you choose or you can keep
your own because there's i think there's
benefits and like drawbacks to all of
them
druid
that's the one i would pick and you're
the first person to pick that one so i
can control your mind so i can make you
uh watch eternals
that's fair that's really fair look at
the views
yeah uh leah what about you
either
sprite or fastos because i think those
are practical powers to to use in the
real world i think yeah that's exactly
my answer as well we've been asked this
a lot so we've had a lot of time to
think i i think but i think the more i
think about it the more i like
sprites superpower just if i was to use
that tomorrow in today's world it would
be quite a cool party trick wouldn't it
yeah
i mean you'll never have to wait in line
at tsa ever again like that's like the
best part you will never have to do our
own interviews we could make someone yes
yeah honestly you could i know this is
not the the easiest day so yeah you can
plop someone down in that chair for you
um
kit i wanted to talk about your
character because you've said um i think
quite often how he gets to represent
humanity in this and just sort of being
like an average guy
what did you feel sort of like how did
you approach that that aspect of it in
the character because i do feel like i
said yesterday he definitely takes in a
lot
very easily and without getting spooked
by it
that that's kind of what i i liked about
him that was there in the first sort of
iterations of the of script that i read
and then talking to chloe it's that
he wasn't he's not someone who gets
phased by things
and i
think that's what um
cersei likes in him and i think that's
what we as an audience like in him that
we're
that he's he's a cool customer for a
human anyway who's someone who doesn't
have any powers that he can use
he's um
he shows some kind of
human heroic ability at the start
yeah i absolutely love that um leah i'll
ask you um
to go ahead and say for this one that
your character
she obviously looks like a child but
then is supposed to have been on earth
for eons but more importantly you had to
with like a lot of non-verbal things
sort of portray
an old soul so i'm just wondering how
you and chloe worked on that because she
has to have like looks and sort of i
would say not necessarily dialogue but
just little things that she did to
portray the fact that this is not what
she appears to be in her physical form
yeah i think chloe cast a lot of the
actors because they were similar to
their characters and i found that i was
very similar to my character especially
in that way i've been told a lot of my
life that i i sort of am an old soul so
i was sort of i was able to relate to
her
um
i mean
of course she gives little notes here
and there on set and we discussed it a
lot but she she did refer me maggie
smith she wanted me to watch a couple of
her movies and sort of get into that old
lady mindset dawn i want to bring it
back um to you because
it's it's like gildamesh is supposed to
be literally the strongest man his sign
that lauren was so cool to like teach us
yesterday is literally like strong man
pretty much
but there's a lot of strong people in
the mcu there's hulk there's thor
there's captain marvel
do you think you can take him like like
do you think gilgamesh is going to be he
could go toe-to-toe and take it down and
who would you want to go toe-to-toe with
hulk
paul he seems like he's true he's the
strongest maybe uh maybe i knock him
down i knock him down a couple times and
then i can show yeah you could show it i
wouldn't want to be on the other end of
hulk but also captain marvel she's like
a photon like so i don't know if that if
that one like pays into it but good on
you for either way um kid i watched your
jimmy fallon interview a little while
ago
did game of thrones like just innately
train you not to give away spoilers like
are you like uber spoiler sensitive
because i feel like
you more than anybody i met you seemed
like you would know because he was
trying to get you to like give away
spoilers in that in that jimmy fallon
interview
yeah it's a unique skill that i seem to
have um it's one of those skills in life
that you don't realize you're going to
pick up isn't it or you'll be really
good at not giving away spoilers
um
i i truly
believe in my heart of hearts
that um spoiling things for people is
a worse thing to do than being seen
lying or covering up in these kind of
interviews so i'm quite happy to cover
up
be deceitful as long as it's not going
to spoil stuff for people yeah no that's
a good way to be and i think the
audience is 100 behind you but i do not
envy the task of having to do it because
i wouldn't last 10 minutes um marvel
would like i'd be like the way they
treat tom holland where they have like
four people around him to protect him
from doing anything i mean we're scared
of them we would never want to sing
terrifying um don again you've done some
incredible like work your filmography is
so great but i have to think when you
started telling the people around you
that you were going to be in a marvel
movie there was some interesting
reactions so i'm just curious who had
the best reaction to your casting
actually uh
i couldn't tell anybody for a while
but uh finally i get to tell everybody
around me and then my family my family
and yeah they are they were so happy and
then
they are all marvelous fans so
you know they couldn't believe it but uh
and you know it's one of this is like
dream come true you know
i love it and leah what about you who
had the best reaction to your casting
oh gosh
my whole family freaked out i don't i
don't think they ever thought in a
million years that like something like
this could happen to me
um
my mom started crying my dad started
crying
i mean
i feel like everyone really freaked out
equally my brothers were
so shocked that i was gonna be a lego
and be an action figure and be in movies
they were i don't know
i mean everyone freaked out
um i love that and i love that everyone
cried because that's probably like the
right reaction and kit like i don't know
if everyone knew what game of thrones
was when you first got cast for that but
people knew when you walked out on stage
at d23 that's a big deal so yeah who
around you had a big reaction and what
did they say my agent
[Laughter]
he's very happy
your agent genuinely he's gent kirk my
one of my agents is genuinely a massive
mcu fan so he was he was thrilled
when you love something
you protect it
this is a movie that goes where marvel
has really never gone before and there's
so many firsts within the movie i'm just
curious
for you
where was those conversations happening
were they organic in the script it was
something you had to then go back to
marvel and sort of check with how did
that um how did those moments come about
um well you know it's a very kind of
evolving and uh uh organic uh process
and and um but i do give credit to
marble for setting the foundation when i
came into the project
in the treatment they've worked with the
fur pulse uh most of these changes in
these four firsts you're talking about
is already in there my job is to try to
make sure they don't just exist on
screen for the sake of existing but
these
are human and uh relatable and authentic
i love how you put that also you had a
very herculean task of introducing these
10 characters and i would say you know a
few other very important
supplemental characters in
less than two and a half hours and you
did it in a way that i think is
different from a lot of what we could
say superhero team-ups a lot of them
approach it the same you know this the
old-fashioned way we're gonna do a
montage and this is what they all do
and you decided to go different so talk
about your choice there for how you
brought each character in to show what
they do
i think that's a very kind of evolving
collaborative process to get to this
point you know there was the treatment
starting with this idea for this to be
sort of a global charting
journey in present day but also going in
the past throughout history and we learn
these characters
as stories moves along
and and and they their arc actually move
our story forward so that was the
conception that i thought was very
wonderful when i came into the process
it's already there and then
cast comes in new ideas comes in you
know stories evolve and then
once we finish shooting there's that
very long editing process we had worked
with two incredible editors uh craig
wood and dan tickner and that's for a
long time you know what stays what goals
it was a it was a long process yeah i've
heard a lot of filmmakers describe it as
you know shooting the movie is really
like planting the seeds and editing is
the harvest you'll find out what you
planted when you when you go into the i
love that saying i i'm very much of an
editor director so so for me that's a i
love that process yeah and again let's
be honest you did an amazing harvest the
film is gorgeous and it really has a
pace to it and an epicness to it that i
think would be
uh difficult to describe to i think most
folks without them having seen it that
being said i know you're an mcu fan
and you got to kind of create your own
world and sort of traverse times kind of
separate from the mcu timeline but is
there one particular i would say moment
in the mcu history that you would want
to like dive into and maybe like either
be a spectator or jump right in
oh wow you mean like the moment in the
film that already happened yeah like any
of the other 12 25 mcu films if you
could sort of like
yeah step back from it and take a look
which one would you want to see
i mean
the first avengers was
you know you can't
uh
download
the cameo in normal land a little easter
egg in there for a reason that was a big
turning point but um the winter soldier
that movie i think it was civil war and
winter soldier those two that moment
when bucky barnes came into
cap's life you know yeah and how how
difficult that was for him for for two
people who can't find
their sense of belonging in modern world
and now they had was each other but they
were i asked with each other this kind
of impossible love they have for each
other was very moving for me yes i'm
taking it back to what you were saying
too about the collaborative process and
how things came together i know that
that is partially why the reason maybe
you tricked kumail into the bollywood
dance scene
but like legit i have to ask was that
something that like well we were going
to do an action scene and now you want
to do a bollywood or did you really know
that i'm probably just going to have to
wait to tell him about this because he's
going to freak out which i would totally
understand i'm going to let him stick to
that version of the story
[Laughter]
okay you know
look it's it was evolving actually i
would say at some point it was an action
slash dance sequence because you know
the movies they they have action and
then dancing at the same time
so i just you know maybe have taken the
action out and that's fair
a little wide last year and there to
your cast i think it's in the in the
contract i honestly think i don't blame
you especially against your point
there's so much there's so many moving
parts that even if you intended to tell
the truth it's probably not going to
stay the truth for very long absolutely
thank you
thank you
yeah i appreciate it um obviously i know
kevin and you talked about jack kirby
and i know that you went to places
outside of the comic book pages for
inspiration but within the comic book
world was there a particular run or a
particular storyline that you
really wanted to sort of center it in on
and and
i guess draw inspiration for where these
characters go or did you want to
write your own book i think the
these i mean comic books are always
ahead of movies
they were kind of movies in many many
ways you know and i think when jack
kirby created eternals it was always
supposed to exist on the peripheral of
what was very popular at the time these
other characters that we know really
well so he wanted to tell this really
big story he want to talk about
a lot of questions that humanity has
pondered since the dawn of time
through this group of people who very
much exist on the peripheral have been
watching us and i i just i love that and
i i like telling stories about people
from the prayer for the society you know
so that immediate draw from me but then
i think the fur poles and nate moore and
kevin
they did a really good job of also
looking at neil gaiman right there's
some ideas in that um i think they came
up with a really impressive structure a
story that that i was immediately going
this is the one for me yeah i love the
internet the internet's gonna go crazy
with that whole neil gaiman ripped from
the eternal sort of thing i love that
real quick before i get out of here you
mentioned how you placed your avengers
uh easter egg in nomad land which i
definitely caught when i saw it out in
the parking lot at the rose bowl that
first night
but
this film you have more than a few dc
references like you know they call him
superman and then we talk about batman
and alfred and i'm wondering do you
think of the eternals as the marvel's
justice league or more importantly do
you think they exist
in the same universe and would like to
see that potential crossover i know the
studios will never let it happen but
would you
i mean of course i do who do you who
doesn't want to see that crossover um
but we shouldn't always get what we want
maybe it's not good for us
maybe something should you know should
be held back but i think
we're in the business of um
telling
modern versions of mesology of myths
from all cultures superman exists in
many many cultures and and the creation
the comics of clark kent and then all
the brilliant filmmakers that brought
him
to the screen
they are doing their own personal modern
version of that mythology icarus is our
version of that but that doesn't mean we
can't
pay tribute and have a good time with
the ones that are so iconic that we love
you know and also gilgamesh
isn't you know he he watches
tv you know he watches
showtime and butcher's movies you'll see
if i want to dd these things um and uh
he i think he likes batman
you can't protect
any of them
[Music]
you